what was your favorite thing that you've
created maybe yourself eat
not you created but this whole
all of these efforts have created in
terms of meal
like you said cookies what are we
talking about that's a hard question um
it's just okay not the favorite but like
something that pops into memory that
brought you joy
the malomar
everybody loved the malamar it was so
very often we made
like raw vegan versions of things that
people are
um familiar with
so it was a
i think it was pecans it was like a
salty
cookie made with nuts and then covered
in chocolate and then there's a big blob
of
coconut cream um i love coconuts which
it didn't taste coconutty
um our ice cream was made with a coconut
also it's like the meat from coconuts
pureed and then there's some soaked
cashews in there but anyways a blob of
vanilla flavored cream kind of like a
you know like a healthy natural version
of fluff
i don't know if you're familiar with
fluff
basically every single word you say i'm
not familiar with you should see my diet
i don't
it's like steak and vegetables a fluff
is like a thing that i remember it from
my childhood like peanut butter and
fluff is a ridiculously delicious
comment is it fluffy or is it it's like
a marshmallow it's basically like
like if you softened marshmallows and
made it into a
luxurious
amazing goose oh so it's like a face and
then put it in a jar
okay and then make a spreadable
spreadable marshmallows kind of oh i see
i think that's yes so spreadable
marshmallows got it yeah so there's a
big blob i didn't know that existed
that's a thing fluff fluff i know does
everyone for you do people know about
this
oh yeah everybody knows
people i mean i think so people know
about fluff and see i think i went
i i took the road less traveled by you
know i went the the peanut butter and
nutella road in terms of spreadable
things nutella is like the chocolate
version
and then fluff is like the vanilla
equivalent sort of cool but i think
commercial fluff that you buy in the
store is just like sugar and whatever
else they put in there
um
anyway not actually fluffy it's it's
kind of fluffy okay but it's wet because
nutella is it's like fluffy
yeah it's it so it's like nutella if you
whipped it and then kind of got a little
bit like a little bit aerated okay so
it's a bit more fluffy so fluff was a
part of the formula here so it was fun
but so the the coconut cream
that we made
was like a healthy version of fluff
oh kind of nice except it would you know
you could make a quenelle like a like a
little scoop of it and it would stay in
that form
malomars were refrigerated and then
there's like chocolate
um drizzled over that so it had that
like salty
sweet thing going on um that was
probably my favorite
that's a dessert
yeah it was like a it was like a dessert
snack it wasn't as you wouldn't order it
on the restaurant menu but in the
takeaway you could get them or sometimes
some people would get them um
shipped on dry ice and pay a lot of
money
like a lot of money to have them shipped
on dry ice
people are funny i know i kind of want
to like name drop because it was tom
brady used to order them oh that's
awesome yeah they would order those
shipped
on ice
you